this video is sponsored by Squarespace
an all-in-one platform that makes it
easy to make an amazing website at
Apple's 2019 iPhone event they put a
huge focus on the iPhone 11 pro but
personally I think that the real winner
from the show is the standard iPhone 11
both for Apple and everyone else in this
video I'll explain exactly why and talk
about some fixes that were made this
time around when iPhone 10 r was
announced a lot of people were really
iffy about it from the lack of 3d touch
the single camera the higher price and
definitely the LCD display with the
resolution just slightly higher than
720p and some other things that ended up
giving it some bad press but in the past
year it has really redeemed itself the
display was much better than expected
and even though it can't compete when
placed side by side with an OLED it's
definitely one of the best LCD displays
out there because of its lower
resolution and larger battery than a 10
s it had the best battery life out of
any iPhone I see people with 10 ARS way
more often than with a 10 s and this was
confirmed when I stopped on my local
t-mobile store and the rep told me that
the ten are out cells the 10s four to
one that is crazy
there are many reasons for a success a
major one being that it doesn't cost a
thousand dollars even though I really
like the 6.1 inch size in the battery
life there were a few things that really
bugged me about it and forced me to use
the iPhone 10 s instead with iPhone 11
Apple has made a dramatic shift in
strategy there are the clearly visible
differences but also some subtle ones
that you probably didn't notice I will
let you know all of those details after
a quick message about our sponsor
Squarespace I have been recommending
Squarespace for over five years now and
that's because I've made websites from
scratch from custom templates and I've
even tried multiple platforms and
Squarespace is by far my most
recommended method whether you're
wanting to build a portfolio site
ecommerce blog or anything else they
have got you covered
with great cross-platform designs to
choose from and built-in security
certificates and SEO tools this means
that your website will rank much better
in searches and that's all included for
one low price making Squarespace not
only easy and fantastic looking but also
an amazing value
head to squarespace.com slash Mac stack
for a no credit card required trial and
if you sign up you'll get 10%
your first purchase of a website or
domain now there were a few sneaky
differences between the iPhone 10 R and
the 10 s that almost nobody knew about
especially when buying the first one was
that the back glass of the 10 R was made
from a weaker glass material than the 10
s and since the whole back is glass and
it cost so much to fix that was
definitely a downside the new iPhone 11
now uses the same exact class as the
11pro both on the front and the rear and
Apple says that this glass is the
strongest glass and any smartphone which
gives more confidence in case of a drop
the iPhone 10s uses a gigabit class LTE
chip but the 10 R had slower LTE that
was just named LTE advanced many people
complained about slower speeds or weaker
reception but the new iPhone 11 Apple
has now included gijiba LTE in the
iPhone 11 as well the 11pro still has
better antennas but this upgrade is much
appreciated another major downside was
that the single lens camera could only
take portraits of people and only if
their face was visible in the shot if
you want to take a cool shot of anything
else including a pet you were out of
luck knife on 11 fixes this and now you
can take a portrait photo of just about
anything I feel like if Apple didn't add
the ultra wide lens into the iPhone 11
it would be too similar to the iPhone 10
R and the wide-angle lens was a smart
choice since it's more handy than having
a telephoto since for that you can
actually crop in especially with the new
good algorithms if you own an iPhone 7
or a plus and you weren't willing to
spend over $1000 for a phone upgrade you
would have had to go to the iPhone 10 R
which many people wouldn't want to
because it has a single lens it's kind
of a downgrade but now I think that most
people would gladly trade that telephoto
for an ultra wide lens and at the same
time get much better photos including
the new night mode which makes a huge
difference in low-light now on to the
biggest change in the price I personally
was shocked when they showed a lowered
price $6.99 a set of 750 that just does
not seem Apple like why in the world
would they want to drop the price while
at the same time making this a higher
quality and feature-rich phone well they
really want you to upgrade sales have
been dropping as people are growing
tired of rising prices
and they're holding onto their phones
longer and some people are actually
switching to Android phones because the
competition is so strong but that's not
the only thing Apple is now becoming
more of a service company instead of a
hardware company and to feed the
explosive growth that they are seeing in
services they need people to buy more
iPhones they are even given away a free
year of their new streaming service with
every new purchase
so if lowering the price of the iPhone
gets more people to try it and get
hooked then that's exactly what they
will do since this first year can really
make or break the success of Apple TV
plus - 11 in my opinion is the best
value for the money iPhone in a long
while and pricing it at a lower $699
will finally get a lot of people to give
up their older iPhone and also sign up
for services the iPhone 11 does have
some downsides such as no fast charger
in the box but do keep in mind that it
could still accept one anger just
released an ultra small low price fast
adopter for just $20 and with a
certified cable you'll get the same fast
charging as the pros I'll go ahead and
leave a link to them down in the video
description so will you finally be
upgrading from your older iPhone let me
know down in the comments section below
and if you want to see our comparison of
the 11 and the 11 Pro once we get those
in our hands click that circle above to
subscribe and enable notifications down
below this has been Max's max tech and I
will see you in the next video
[Music]